For this quiz, your goal is to define a procedure.
We'll call it abbaize.
This is very useful if you need to come up with names,
and what it does is take 2 strings as its inputs and outputs a string
that is the first input, followed by 2 repetitions of the second input, followed by the first input.
As an example, if we called abbaize, passing in the string 'a' and the string 'b'--
single character strings--
what we should get as a result is the string 'abba'.
If we called abbaize, passing in the string 'dog' and the string 'cat',
what we should get is the string 'dogcatcatdog',
and there aren't any spaces between the strings.
They're just all pasted together.